hello hello is this Donna Strickland hi
this is Adam Smith calling from
nobelprize.org the official web site at
the Nobel Prize in Stockholm okay hi
first of all congratulations on the
order the Nobel Prize thank you very
much
what was your immediate thought on
hearing the news well obviously like I
think like many people have set up we've
wondered if it was a prank but then I
knew it was the right day and it would
have been the cruel prank that is what I
was thinking were you sleeping with
Nicole came it's um it's fairly amazing
I don't know if there's another case if
somebody being awarded a Nobel Prize for
their very first scientific paper
I sort of feel like I just lucked into
this whole thing I have to say that well
[Laughter]
you must have been a naturally gifted
experimentalist where did it come from
do you think I don't know I mean it was
it was just a fun thing to do and so I
enjoyed putting many hours into it yet
it is the one time of my life that I
worked and but you know it was a fun
time in the field of short pulse lasers
and it was a fun group to be in and
so you put in the long hours it's the
classic vision of the experimental
physicists or tinkering around in the
lab and of course you are the first
female laureates 55 years Marie Curie
everybody comes tonight but I was
thinking oh I even quoted her I cited
her work in my thesis right that's a
nice connection what message do you
think it sends to people
I don't know how to answer that because
I'm not saying I'm not a woman who's
been you know looking at all of these
prices thinking why isn't there a woman
I sort of haven't thought like that but
I know a lot of people I guess do you
look at that I don't know I I hope I
mean I certainly tell the Maria gay
Britton Myers story and I'm happier that
life isn't like that I'm glad there were
trailblazers like ternary jury he didn't
get to have a paid job to the longest
time right she didn't really get to be
recognized as a scientist even though
you know she was doing incredible work
right I think she went hers in the
fifties he was 63 she was awarded 63 and
the work I cite for her started the
whole field of multiphoton ionization
which was the first thing that art laser
was used for and in my thesis and and
that work was done in 1939
it's not what she won the Nobel Prize
for but again it totally changed what
could be done right yes and you just
think how can you go 20 more than 20
years you know I don't know if that was
that one sort of surprise not to get a
Nobel Prize but just to even be
recognized as a scientist yes so so I
think things have totally changed so I
think it will come around and change
yeah I suppose one thing that is going
to happen is that you're going to be
very much in demand how do you think
about that you have a little scared
about that because I was talking to a
previous Nobel Prize winner a few years
back and you know he told me how he flew
a hundred thousand miles you know and
scientists don't even get to fly first
class so that's hard like a year like
you know and it's like oh my goodness
that's a lot yeah at this point this is
this is a pretty surprising point to be
at I mean for anybody it's it's a you've
only heard just a few minutes ago let me
just very briefly about ultra-fast
lasers what's your favorite example of
what they can do oh okay well right
I've taken over doing the undergraduate
labs and I'm trying to think of you know
what was the most exciting things for me
to see okay so you're probably thinking
bigger things
I just think quite late generation is
just one of these remarkable things to
see and actually you know one color of
light goes in to just water or any clear
anything and out comes all the colors of
the rainbow when the pulses are short
and intense enough and it's just
remarkable to sit there and go what
weird all those colors come from it's
not that we don't understand that in
science but it's one of those things
that is just really cool to see like
yeah it's different than Newton seen all
the colors that are in white light we
actually just start with a very narrow
bandwidth and create all of those colors
through the nonlinear interaction with
the medium oh that is magical yes it is
magical and you know it took many years
for scientists to even figure out what
was going on which is also always a fun
you know thing for scientists to do
that's what we like to do is puzzle as
to why something is working but it you
know was tagged it's useful a generation
is used also everywhere so but as you
say what a wonderful demonstration of
what this prize is all about laser light
and matter interaction well goodness
well we'll learn a lot more about all
this when you come to Stockholm in
December we very much look forward to
welcoming you it's a joy to speak with
you and I very much look forward to
meeting you in December